hi I'm Rachel Senna hi I'm Emma Seligman
and I'm Iowa debris hi and we're here to
ask each other questions about our new
movie bottoms tonight is our night we're
getting the couch I'm gonna talk to
Brittany you could say that Isabelle
what would I say hey girl how's your
boyfriend how's his penis
I'm gonna expel you both for committing
a crime against Jeff get out of the car
you can't tell me
come on
um should I start yeah yeah okay so this
is a movie where Josie punches PJ in the
face
um there is a scene yeah where Josie
punches PJ in the face what will you
remember most from making that scene
how hard it was for to nail the
placement where her fist went on your
face yeah the trust the trustful of it
really like I remember honestly the
rehearsal of the punch of to get up to
making of that scene and when we first
started like
be punching each other in the face
because it's sort of like they show you
and you do it slow but then you just
kind of start doing it and it's like
okay punch me yeah yeah I think I'll
remember Rachel falling
because Rachel's a very flat follower I
struggle with Falls
what's your favorite memory of the fight
training for this movie
I feel like what yeah my do you want to
share your favorite no you start when we
were all in a circle like the first day
I wasn't part of the training obviously
like yeah this way at all but I feel
like the first day when we had Devin
McNair our stunt coordinator and she
just like took a moment to be like it's
so beautiful that I'm working with so
many women and like almost started
crying and then like
she literally went backwards and then
she was like all right time to toughen
up never mind no tears allowed um that
was one moment yeah
I was gonna say I loved the training of
the punching each other the falling on
the mats and I think just like the
supportive energy of it where it was
like
there was like some people were better
than others Ruby was incredible so there
were weak links and no no names we have
no idea who they don't know who they are
but and feeling like the support of the
group and then when Emma would come in
at the end of the first week and we did
like show and tell where it's like and I
was like watching us and we're like come
here
and then just like kicking each other
yeah Emma's like sideboarding with a
producer being like I I mean they've got
one more week so
not the ones that you choreographed but
look look what I can do yeah yeah yeah
that was fun that was fun it was fun to
do Show and Tell at the end of the day
Josie and PJ lie about having been to
juvie what's the best lie you've ever
told unless it's still currently going
on yeah you're exempt from
thank you
oh best to lie
I feel like it's all childhood lies I
feel like I I faked a fever with a flat
iron one but I didn't put it straight to
my head you just put it I put it on it I
put it on a um either it was paper towel
or a washcloth and then I put that on my
forehead for a while
um and I faked the fever yeah I also
faked my period by like painting on a
pad and like showing it to my dad and
being like I can't go to swim practice
so I was like literally I was like well
if I lie I go to hell
but dude I'm like I'm like me I'm like
21. I'm like when I go to hell no but I
was um I was like six and we had to
memorize Bible verses for church and say
them at the end of like every Friday uh
for like youth service and I didn't
remember mine in time so I wrote it on
the inside of my arm is that even a lie
is that just me doing something stupid
but I got caught reading it because
obviously I'm like hmm oh Jesus loves me
whatever and obviously I got caught
cause I'm like six and the Sunday school
teacher was like did you literally just
read that off your arm and I was like no
it was like show me your arm then and I
had to show my arm in front of everybody
and then I remember I like ran to the
back of the church and I was like crying
and then my aunt was like literally
everybody can see you like it was fine
like get up you're being nuts I was so
embarrassed yeah yeah can you relate to
that at all I feel like like well now I
feel like now if I ever will you relate
to hell right no I was afraid of how I
kept okay Judaism bragging yeah we I
kept a list of my sins and I would I
remember like one time I was in the
shower and then there was an ant
crawling in the shower and so I put it
in the toilet and then I got back in the
shower and then I thought about it
drowning and I felt guilty and then I
came out of the shower and it was still
swimming and I saved it with a nail file
and I brought it outside what wait it's
okay there's no lie
read the next one
who was the best fighter of the cast
Ruby Ruby Ruby yeah all that Willow
training yeah what was your reaction to
seeing the school's mascot for the first
time on set
well I I got to develop the look of it
so I feel like I was I was very excited
by it I was there in the the yeah I was
excited by the excitement coming from
the costume designer and the production
designer Eunice was hype lots of
meetings about the size and the texture
and the the like the fuzziness of it or
the like yeah with references and models
and whatever but what was it like when
you first saw the mascot
shark yeah to see it on the field to
really see it it was in motion and shot
yeah in motion is a whole other thing
because it it moves the costume it's
alive it's alive Yeah Yeah Yeah that
poor actor it was warm that was the
other thing is I was like it's hot there
was a lot of little fans and taking
breaks yeah of any past show or movie
you've worked on which character would
you love to see join Josie and PJ's
Fight Club Richie from the bear as like
like the assistant coach to Mr G yeah oh
my God and they need to be in matching
track soon well yeah because they're two
like middle-aged men going through
divorces like they need each other bad
and the support they're really at taking
out all of their inner trauma on the
group Evan's also like really funny yeah
yeah easily
wait Richie Evans character yeah it's
polish but doesn't he say Miss Italian
culture yeah and then everybody's like
you're polish okay I feel like the I'm
like we need a little bit of that I just
love that I thought like you were just
like Evan was Italian you're like we
need an Italian no it's just like we've
got an Italian but um
God help us we I think that would be
great what's another character well I
only have should have a baby to pull
from I feel like Polly oh
yeah
would be great I like that I feel like
she'd come in with beaten moves being
like so I planned this already yeah I
actually worked this out with my own
stunt coordinator yeah I'm gonna add
this to the scene yeah what do you think
we're in Ruby as Hazel
they would have a really strange
Alliance I see that just as the two plan
yeah yeah
maybe Alice from bodies because she was
trying to fight she has only W like like
well it doesn't I have to be oh no no it
can be a character from something I've
been here yeah or it can be but okay
never mind no no no no let her have that
yeah yeah
I thought it had to be a character
because like no I can do it I can play
both yeah
um like the mom from calling your mother
Kyra Cedric has I forget the mom's name
but she would be great yeah I think
that's great but yeah that's a perfect
answer yeah yeah okay what is your
favorite onset memory of Marshawn Lynch
oh
tossing a football with him yes oh my
gosh that was fun we had like a heart to
heart one day love and I was just like
literally my life was a dream he's so
nice yeah he's so kind I remember trying
to make him cry with a tear stick and he
hated it so much that's not my favorite
memory of him but it's a distinct one oh
no because his eyes were like he was
like yeah
he was like I can't do this like and
then was like what is that and he was so
game to try it I was like do you want to
put on tear stick for when you're crying
about your divorce and he was like well
I'm game like yeah I couldn't do
anything like a method whatever I'm
literally a football player I can handle
whatever yeah and then he hated the tear
sticks so much this is just a memory
yeah
also running lines with him was like
incredible because he was just like I
want to get it right and I was like
literally every time you open your mouth
you say the funniest thing I've ever
heard of yeah we were like forget the
line literally yeah you don't have to
like you don't even have to be a part of
the script you can play your own
character if you want yeah yeah what's
your favorite memory of shooting the
scene where Josie lightly Taps Jeff with
her car
okay oh sorry no I didn't know I suppose
I don't know what we're thinking we're
entering into our minds I think being in
the car there's something about getting
to like be in a little like venue me and
Havana in between takes like listening
to music or talk you know what I mean
and then being like
like NYX on the app do you know what I
mean getting to like getting to like hit
someone with your car but not really but
like I like um after when we like
there's like a part where we got this we
had to stay in the car while but then
like while uh miles started his
screaming yeah because we couldn't like
we weren't like we couldn't like Drive
Away something about it and so I got to
see miles doing like the different
variations of him screaming for Jeff and
that was just so funny because miles is
a genius yeah he is a genius I think my
favorite part was watching all the
football players run you're good yeah I
think my favorite part was watching all
the football players Run and Jump Off
The Cars
stunts yeah like to roll over the hoods
of the car and stuff yeah
also when the stunt the driver who's
stunt driving the car I got to be in it
and it was like whoo it was a little
roller coaster ride I didn't get to be
in it but you were there in school
it looks like you're pulling away really
good I know it does yeah I did get my
license that year yeah yeah yeah
skirts
we should do quickfire wrap it around
okay of the cast who do you think was
most like their character Ruby
is that crazy oh sorry I know we just
thought we would be faster no I couldn't
think of an idea maybe Ruby maybe Ruby
um Ruby or summer
yeah summer brought a lot yeah yeah
um pretend the senior yearbooks comes
out oh no no that's too hard
um oh
um what color sports did you join in
high school
cross country
of acapella
drama drama film
um I did ballroom dancing for a little
oh my god do you get a character shoe or
a ballroom shoe I did yeah yeah I
thought for a second you said shoot and
I was like what I went to a public
school Noah characters yeah girl we were
dancing in our sneakers it was a little
it was a little it was a little ragtag
yeah